okay we suspected that this would happen
and it has
Steven minuchin 'he's treasury
department has failed to deliver Donald
Trump's tax returns to Congress by the
set deadline the deadline was Tuesday
yesterday lawmakers got nothing Donald
Trump's Treasury secretary Stephen
minuchin said he can't do it until he
knows if the request is consistent with
the law and we're gonna get back to that
statement but if you haven't been
following this I'll remind you how it
all came about congressman Richard Neal
our old congressman in Northampton
Massachusetts does some good things does
some not-so-good things as we reported
on a couple of weeks ago he's on the
House Ways and Means Committee and
there's a law from 1924 which says that
members of the House and Senate who are
on tax writing committees have the
ability to request the tax returns of
any individual or corporation that they
want from the Treasury the law as
written is pretty binary it's something
that if you're on the committee you can
do it's not you get to request it and
the president tells you whether they're
okay with you getting their tax returns
or not if the tax returns happen to be
those of the president it's not you
request it and the Justice Department
can get involved in deciding whether or
not you actually get those tax returns
it's not up to the president it's not up
to the Justice Department the law is
pretty simple but there is one sort of
reasonable hitch in all of this which
has come up and it seems to be implied
in the law but as we know interpreting
what is implied by law is a complicated
thing but the argument that's being made
is that implied implicit in this 1924
law is that if someone from any of these
tax writing committees is requesting the
tax returns of an individual or a
corporation that there should be some
kind of legislative agenda or purpose to
requesting those tax returns it's not
totally clear what that is for Richard
Neal requesting Donald Trump's tax
returns you could argue the legislative
purpose is that depending on what's in
Trump's tax returns Congress might
decide
they need to impeach the President of
the United States if they see something
in there that suggests that there has
been wrongdoing or potential criminal of
financial criminality it's a little bit
of a stretch and ultimately this is
going to be a probably fought by courts
and if indeed it gets to the Supreme
Court we know who is increasingly in
charge there and that's Donald Trump
based on the number of appointments he's
made to that court so the way this might
go is government subpoena of the tax
returns remember that this first request
from Richard Neal was just that it was
just a request the next step would be a
subpoena that would start to get legally
messy and if indeed it gets to the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court is
controlled by Donald Trump in the sense
that he now has a three people on the
court that he selected it is one of the
most conservative courts in a very long
time
and it's also evidence of two justice
systems what's going on if you or I as a
normal person gets a summons from the
court for some legal documents for some
documents rather or gets a summons to
appear by a certain date if I ignore
that and say you know I'm considering
whether the request is consistent with
the law and in the meantime I'm not
going to give you what you want or show
up when you told me to I would be
arrested and brought to court or held in
contempt until I provide those documents
and eventually short of the subpoena
steven minuchin could actually be
charged with inherent content contempt
of Congress contempt of Congress and
taken into custody although obviously
none of us expect that that will happen
because we have two justice systems in
the United States of America the the
other sort of absurd detail about the
argument that he's evaluating the
legality of that request or of whether
this conforms with the law the
legislature wrote the law that allows
this and they are using it to request
Trump's tax returns so in a sense at the
base level of course it's consistent
with the law they wrote the law and now
they're using the law for the per
it was written that one caveat being
does there have to be a demonstrable
legislative purpose to the request for
an individual's tax returns and is one
required I don't know the answer but if
you read the opinions of a number of
different legal experts they say that
that could actually be a reasonably good
argument the question I get to in the
end is will we ever actually see Donald
Trump's tax returns and I don't know the
answer let me know what you think
will we see Trump's tax returns let me
know on Instagram the shows on instagram
at david pakman show i'm on instagram at
david pakman and we'll take a very quick
break here and be right back if you love
learning new things you probably want to
check this out the david pakman show
today is sponsored by Skillshare and
we're giving you two entire months of
free access to Skillshare when you click
the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video